[Music]
modern technology is helping the state
watch its citizens but that same
technology is also letting citizens
watch the state we know that Facebook is
spying on us
we know that Google is spying on us but
those mediums can also become mediums of
Counter forensics we are watching the
Watchers we are reversing the forensic
gaze
[Music]
the rise of social media and the
proliferation of smartphones has made it
easier than ever for people to consume
news but not all this information is
true some governments use these
platforms to disseminate propaganda and
monitor citizens behavior now this
technology has also helped to turn the
tables on of the powerful every comment
every photo every video is a clue to
ultimately getting at the truth the big
challenge is to figure out how we find
all those clues and ultimately use them
almost like pieces in a puzzle
Alexa Koenig is a law professor and
investigator she gathers evidence from
multiple digital sources to investigate
some of the biggest human rights abuses
in the 21st century so many war crimes
cases fall apart at fairly early stages
of prosecution one of the big challenges
is that prosecutors are over relying on
witness testimony and of course with
time and trauma a testimony becomes
fallible miss Kay Nick's team has helped
investigate atrocities in Miami Syria
and Yemen unlike traditional
investigators her team uses open source
evidence
so we brought together people doing big
data analytics satellite imagery remote
sensing people who were thinking through
how cellphones could be harnessed and
support the stories of survivors the
team has investigated atrocities in my
anmar in 2017 the evidence proved that
the army had used facebook's wide reach
in the country to post false information
inciting hatred against the roa Hindu
Muslim minority this type of evidence is
gaining traction and is being used by
the International Criminal Courts open
source information that you can find
online is increasingly being used by
groups like the United Nations and by
the International Criminal Court and it
released its first ever arrest warrant
based on information pulled from social
media in Libya meanwhile Belen cap a
group of open source experts has been
investigating the poisoning of a former
Russian spy sergey skripnikov
Belem CAC disclosed the names of three
Russian agents who they allege were
involved in the attack strengthening the
suspicions that it was sanctioned by the
Russian state in response the Russian
authorities claimed that the men were
tourists but Belen cap proved that the
three men were high-ranking members of
the Russian army one of the agents had
even been honored by President Vladimir
Putin personally what ballon cat did was
they began to comb social media and find
the profiles of the people who were
thought to have been involved that
Russia was saying were just tourists and
ultimately established the true
identities in a way that really shocked
the world
Belem cat cross-referenced photo and
video evidence released by the British
and Russian authorities with social
media to find the men's true identities
this is not the first time a state has
been accused of trying to cover its
tracks
[Music]
governments are trying to release false
information about things that have taken
place we need to not only establish what
has taken place but to deconstruct the
government statements that are
misleading al Wiseman is an open-source
expert based in the UK the most recent
incident which he has investigated
raises questions about the death of
Palestinians during an Israeli airstrike
[Music]
in 2018 these two boys were sitting on a
rooftop they were killed
moments after taking this selfie
the Israeli Armed Forces said they fired
non-lethal warning shots to clear the
area of civilians
they call this tactic knocking on the
roof
hours later the Israeli army released a
video which appears to show full warning
shots followed by the main strike but
forensic architecture stitched together
mobile phone and CCTV footage disputing
their claim they allege the Israeli army
did not release a video of the first
shot which killed the boys
instead it substituted it with a video
of the third strike from another angle
the Israeli army denied distorting
evidence
[Music]
investigating state operations isn't
cheap it takes time and resources one
big question is always where's the money
coming from to do this kind of work
there are some individual donors who
really believe in the power of
technology for social good and
increasingly we do see some states that
are really interested in the power and
possibility of pulling together
information the evidence and practices
of groups such as Belen cap and forensic
architecture are open to everyone this
evidence is traceable and verifiable but
lawmakers must approach it with caution
the use of this evidence in court is in
its infancy and raises several problems
I think so few judges today are trained
in ways to really interrogate what makes
for a good digital investigation that
there is really a two-fold risk the
first risk is that they're going to look
at this very slick sexy package and
they're going to find it so convincing
that they ultimately don't interrogate
the underlying bits of information the
second risk of course is that they're
just going to look at this and say I
have no way to understand kind of the
original sources of this information and
so they dismiss it out of hand
it is increasingly difficult to separate
fact from fiction but crowdsource
investigations
offer a new way giving a voice to
victims and holding the powerful to
account
you